2020 was ... not a good year, to put
it lightly. The COVID-19 pandemic
reached practically every corner of the globe,
forcing countries to issue lockdowns. Millions
found themselves unemployed as businesses closed.
People couldn't even escape from
their troubles at the movie theaters,
as the likes of No Time to Die, Black Widow,
and Fast & Furious 9 all got pushed into 2021.
Match.com seems to understand how uniquely
difficult the year was for single people.
In early December, in association with Ryan
Reynolds' production company Maximum Effort,
the company released a commercial highlighting the
relatable hope that 2021 will be better than 2020.
In the ad spot, Satan strikes up a new romance
with the human personification of 2020,
and it's a match made in Hell.
"Call me 2020."
The commercial is enough to give
viewers a serious sense of déjà vu,
as they watch the couple exercise in an abandoned
gym and hoard toilet paper. But as you watch the
Match.com ad, you may also start to feel as though
you've seen the woman who plays 2020 before.
As it turns out, the actress in the
Match.com commercial is Natalie Roy,
who has appeared in numerous
TV shows and films in the past.
Roy has been acting professionally since 2005,
when she made her first television appearance
in the Canadian drama series On the Run. Over
the years, she's popped up in various guest
spots on a number of TV series — including
Blindspot on NBC and The Affair on Showtime.
In 2018, Roy had a prominent role as Claire in
the short-lived dark comedy series After, which
follows a widower who attempts to start dating
once again. The show, which also stars Joshua
Schubart as Jeremy and Olivia Baptista as Benny,
was nominated for six Indie Series Awards in 2019.
Roy isn't just a talent in front of the cameras
— she's also served as a writer, director,
and/or producer on a number of short films.
She released a book in 2013 called 30 Years,
30 Lessons, showcasing the stories,
dreams, and moments that make up a life,
as told from the perspective of
a 30-year-old woman trying to
attain her goals. You can watch a promo she
filmed for the book on her YouTube channel.
More recently, Roy appeared opposite
Adrian Paul, Vivica A. Fox, Sean Young,
and more in the thriller film A Beautiful
Distraction, about people who come to realize
that they're living in an alternate timeline,
completely different from the one they once did.
And just a few days into 2021, Roy popped
up in an episode of the crime dramedy series
Bull, playing a character named Olivia
Wright in the fifth episode of season 5.
It's clear from her extensive résumé
that Roy is a multi-faceted talent,
and the Match.com 2020 commercial has introduced
her to a massive new audience. After "Match Made
in Hell" dropped, two more ads were released:
"When Satan Met 2020" and "Sneak peek at 2021."
"I've dated much worse guys than him.
Much worse. I mean, at least he's famous."
The ads have amassed millions of views and
a ton of positive praise, with people really
seeming to love the irreverent take on the last
year as well as the remastered version of the
country-pop song "Love Story" by Taylor Swift
that's featured in the "Match Made in Hell" spot.
In an interview with CBC News,
Roy had the chance to talk about the process
of bringing the commercial to life, stating,
"I do feel the scripts were so funny, and
the physical comedy of the difference in
size between myself and the gentleman playing
the Devil was already so much great material
that I actually feel like I
didn't have to do much work."
With so much exposure,
expect plenty of good things to come
for Natalie Roy in the years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus, even more
Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.